[Musica]
il tema di oggi è rigenerazione
cosa significa rigenerazione
io ho cercato significato e ho trovato
che si tratta del ristabilirsi
l'integrità strutturale fisiologica in
tessuti organi parti del corpo
precedentemente perduti aspettare
appena ho letto questa definizione
mi è venuto in mente
una situazione un periodo della mia vita
molto particolare
mi è venuto in mente quando in seguito a
un terribile incidente e mi sono trovato
in coma
completamente
in condizioni completamente disperate
avevo perso praticamente tutto avevo
solamente due organi che funzionavano
cuore cervello
tutti gli altri erano spenti
grazie alle cure che ho ricevuto è anche
la tempra del corpo sono riuscito a
recuperare a recuperare un po alla volta
un pezzettino alla volta
la salute il mio corpo si è auto
rigenerato
e mi sono reso conto
a distanza di tempo che questa
esperienza che all'inizio può sembrare
veramente
traumatica
in realtà quando mi trovo a vivere delle
situazioni complicate mi dà un'energia
incredibile perché adesso mi permette di
dare veramente valore a tutte le cose
che
tutte le volte che penso a quanto è
difficile fare questo a quanto difficile
fare quello ricordo che
momenti difficili io ho già attraversati
e questi momenti difficili adesso mi
permettono di dare veramente valore
anche alle piccole cose anche al
semplice respirare muovermi
pensare a sorridere correre il fatto che
la rigenerazione che è avvenuta dopo
l'incidente è stata parziale perché si
copre comparato quasi tutte le
funzionalità del mio corpo parte la
vista
infatti in seguito agli incidenti che
sono rimasto cieco
questo fatto
ha per forza di cose
comportato un altro tipo di
rigenerazione nella mia vita
una rigenerazione
psicologica psicologica e sociale
e perché ciò venisse
è stato necessario abbinare a questo a
questa rigenerazione anche un valore un
valore secondo me molto importante
quello dell'altruismo
mi sono trovato a un certo punto della
mia vita che
circa un anno dopo l'incidente che avevo
recuperato una buona funzionalità fisica
però completamente cambiata non sapevo
più come si facevano tante cose non
avevo più un lavoro non era tutto nuovo
tutto di d'aversa tutto da imparare
e quando mi sono domandato come posso
fare per andare avanti per trovare
ancora un senso un significato
ho fatto la stessa cosa che il mio corpo
mentre io ero da un'altra parte ha fatto
per me e quindi
compiere quelle cose anche minime che
era nella sua possibilità di compiere
con le minime risorse di cui disponevo
io mi sono reso conto che potevo dare un
piccolo contributo
alle persone alcune persone che si
trovavano attorno a me nello specifico
mi sono trovato a
frequentare un'associazione
di persone con disabilità e
quel po che potevo fare era
essere assieme a loro a raccontare un po
la mia esperienza a portare
testimonianze di supporto di coraggio di
forza cose minime cose piccole perché
appunto e ancora dopo non avevo ancora
imparato a vivere al buio e queste
piccole cose mi hanno portato indietro
del valore
ecco che un passo alla volta
ho avuto modo di rendermi conto quanto
mettere a disposizione degli altri
ciò che si era
da valore alla tua vita
questa
appunto con più valore nella mia vita io
ho ritrovato un po alla volta la
felicità
un po alla volta il senso di vivere e
quindi ho cominciato a uscire di più ho
cominciato ad avere più fiducia in me
stesso a
poco ho ricominciato a vivere sogni
ambizioni e a inseguire un qualcosa che
per me era molto importante la libertà
autonomia
all'inizio è stato sicuramente una sfida
perché immaginatevi di uscire di casa
non vedete assolutamente niente e dovete
muovervi nell'ignoto
è stata tosta
come aveva fatto precedentemente mi
hanno domandato in che modo io avrei
potuto affrontare questa nuova sfida
e l'ho fatto
applicando alcune scoperte che avevo
fatto in quel periodo ovvero che
se si è disposti a fidarsi di se stessi
degli altri e della vita ci si ha
fiducia in quello che ci accade
la vita sia per noi
quindi esserci che un po per gioco un po
per caso mi sono trovato un giorno a
dover spostarmi da solo affidandomi
appunto alle persone che non conoscevo e
questa cosa che è successa a centinaia
di chilometri da casa all'inizio ho
avuto tanta paura poi però è successo
che le persone beni venivano da me e mi
davano una mano mi devono una mano per
compiere tutti quegli spostamenti di cui
avevo bisogno
per uscire dalla stazione del treno
raggiungere un taxi raggiungere tutti i
posti che volevo raggiungere
quella sera quando sono rientrato a casa
sono si sono
materializzate nella mia mente
un'infinità di di nuove situazioni e tra
tutte queste una in particolare
io se riesco veramente a fidarmi
come ho fatto oggi di me stesso delle
persone del fatto che quello che farò
sarà supportato da
un energia superiore e domani posso
riprendere uscire e girare tutte le
città che voglio
questa è una cosa ho pensato molto
importante perché
se si pensa a quello che la maggior
parte delle persone credono ovvero che
girando si incontrano tante persone
cattive ti possono capitare tante cose
brutte
negative io posso dimostrare qualcosa di
nuovo di di
di anche rivoluzionario se vogliamo
adesso inizia a fare un viaggio per
d'italia
affidandomi alle persone che incontrò
casualmente
racconto questa mia esperienza
attraverso i social attraverso gli
strumenti che era proprio più opportuni
e quindi lancia un messaggio di fiducia
a tutte le persone che mi seguono
c'era qualcosa però che e non tornava
c'era c'era come un blocco
e mi è venuta in mente una lezione che
avevo imparato un anno un paio di anni
prima durante questo seminario sulle
facoltà di ravello sulla crescita
personale che mi ha cambiato la vita
i limiti cominciano e finiscono nella
nostra testa
perché quindi avrei dovuto porre limiti
a un'esperienza del genere
il limite questo caso era geografico
l'italia
quindi ho deciso di ignorando con
l'inglese di estendere questo mio
viaggio all'europa ha detto faccio un
viaggio per l'europa e questo bene state
rifinite a vestendo a tutte le persone
europee
c'era qualcosa che non tornava
insomma l'europa
ecco che è nata un'idea meravigliosa che
ne è andato la vita quella di compiere
il giro del mondo partendo da solo e
affidandomi a tutte le persone che avrei
incontrato lungo il percorso
in questo caso la rigenerazione si
avvaleva di un valore meraviglioso che
quello della fiducia
e questo è questa combinazione
ha fatto sì che io il 2 aprile del 2013
sono partito a nogara spesso le persone
domandano laddove si è tradito la casa
mia a e dove le finito sempre a casa
meno
il fatto che nel mezzo ci sono stati 90
paesi in due anni e mezzo attraversato
90 paesi in tutti i continenti e ogni
volta in maniera diversa in forme
diverse la fiducia ha fatto sì che
succedessero delle cose incredibili
a volte un po sconvolgenti comunque
sempre la tesi iniziale è stata
supportato
terminato questo viaggio
incredibile
sono successe tante altre cose
una delle quali è caduto proprio l'anno
scorso
proprio quando stava per poco prima che
scoppiasse la pandemia e assumesse le
dimensioni che poi abbiamo tutti avuto
modo di comprendere
io ho deciso di prendere una piccola
vacanza e andare a trovare un amico che
avevo conosciuto tra l'altro durante il
mio viaggio
e sono andato in columbia
pochi giorni dopo è successo quello che
è successo e sono rimasto chiuso in quel
paese per due mesi al rientro
tornato a casa mia ho dovuto passare due
settimane in isolamento fiduciario due
settimane chiusi in casa da solo cosa
potevo fare e tra l'altro stato anche
guardando la situazione che stava
capitando in italia
tutte le attività chiuse quasi tutte le
attività chiuse persone che non sapevano
cosa fare gente che continua a ripetere
aspettiamo aspettiamo
aspettiamo cosa e io qualche giorno dopo
il mio rientro
ho deciso di non aspettare e lasciare
lasciare che le cose swiss ero
in questo caso la rigenerazione
si è agganciata abbracciato la speranza
in un futuro migliore
la speranza e con la volontà anche di
agire senza stalli con le mani mano
attendere che il cambiamento arrivi ma
essere noi i primi a vivere il
cambiamento
e l'ho fatto in maniera un po
particolare che adesso vi racconto
cercando di farvi capire quanto in
realtà come dicevo prima i limiti sono
nella nostra testa
ho trovato mattino una pubblicità su
facebook che parlava di puzzle di archi
base bianchi mi sono detto beh allora ti
faccio più ci sono bianchi li comunque
li faccio anch'io e poi ho detto non sa
che prende un puzzle bianco il soggiorno
dovrà averne già uno composto che si
abbiamo colorato non vedo niente e provo
a vedere cosa succede
lo immaginate una persona cieca che si
mette a fare un puzzle non un puzzle 3x2
il paese in cui ho cominciato era da
mille pezzi l'ho distrutto
e ho iniziato a vedere se era per caso
possibile per ricomporlo non sono
partito da un limite ovvero non lo posso
fare e sono partito da una domanda posso
io farlo in che modo posso fare questa
cosa la risposta è stata provandoci
ho iniziato questa avventura non senza
difficoltà e dopo diverse ore di
esercizio aveva completato la cornice
esterna sì avevo aggiunto alcune decine
di pezzi sì ce l'avevo messo tantissimo
tempo e secondo due calcoli completare
questo mille pezzi mi avrebbe richiesto
un paio d'anni
allora cosa pensava forse ho fatto il
passo più lungo della gamba
facciamo un qualcosa di più semplice
come non sono partito direttamente da
girare il mondo in un colpo solo sono
partito da fare piccoli viaggetti mi
sono comprato un passo di un po più
piccolo da 150 grazie e con un problema
più piccolo è stato più facile trovare
delle soluzioni che mi hanno permesso di
elaborare delle strategie nuove e quindi
ho comprato un po più grande da 300
pezzi
e con le strategie nuove questo paese da
300 pezzi ho completato in un paio di
settimane
e allora hanno comprato uno ancora più
grande da 500 pezzi
e anche completando questo puzzle ho
scoperto ulteriori strategie
ho deciso di comprare un pausa mille
pezzi nel rispetto di due anni che avevo
ipotizzato fino a pochi mesi prima lo
completato in poco meno di 200 ore
anche in questa avventura ho scoperto
nuove tecniche nuove strategie e sapete
una cosa
alcune settimane fa ho completato in
circa 70 ore di lavoro un puzzle da due
mie pezzi e oltre a questo ci sono
riuscito a mettere a punto anche una
tecnica che consente alle persone
prive di lista di sviluppare un puzzle
in alcune condizioni
addirittura più velocemente di decidere
questo mi ha fatto riflettere su un
concetto di base da una metafora
bellissima per parlare di un valore
secondo me importantissimo soprattutto
in questo periodo quello dell'inclusione
nel puzzle tutti i pezzi sono diversi
non c'era un uguale a un altro eppure
ognuno la sua importanza non c'è il
pezzo che piccolo che vale di meno di
quello più grande non c'è il terzo meno
colorato che vale di più di quello più
colorato tutti i pezzi sono fondamentali
per completare un disegno meraviglioso e
per far sì che ognuno acquisti un
significato superiore
la società in cui viviamo nella stessa
cosa è un puzzle se ne pensiamo di
valere di più degli altri ci pensiamo
che alcuni che alcune persone non siano
necessarie o che abbiano meno valore
stiamo togliendo qualora noi stessi
questo periodo che abbiamo attraversato
e che sta ancora attraversando
deve essere di insegnamento a questa
nuova consapevolezza
ognuno ha un suo significato
fondamentale
ognuno ha un suo valore è
è importante che si lavori in sincronia
e in sinergia per far sì che ognuno di
noi possa trovare la sua collocazione
nella vita
le persone che si rivolgono a me
per affrontare un cambiamento un
percorso di crescita personale
spesso lo fanno perché hanno visto tutto
quello che io ho fatto
in questi in questi ultimi anni e quindi
io che cosa propongo a loro di fare
nella stessa cosa io propongo in alcuni
casi io propongo loro un'esperienza di
privazione
non rendo ceco nessuno almeno in maniera
terminale sia chiaro però questa
esperienza di di privazione può aiutare
le persone a rendersi conto quanto sia
importante ciò che già a ciò che già di
cui già dispongono spesso vediamo tante
cose per scontato
in realtà nulla nessuno ed ascoltato
nella vita in realtà sarebbe
importante riuscire a vivere ogni nostro
singolo secondo ogni nostro istante come
un valore preziosissimo se facciamo a
fare questo la regione la jeep e
rigenerazione seguendo la definizione
che nato all'inizio non è semplicemente
un ristabilirsi vista di lire di un
integrità ma ti porta a raggiungere un
livello superiore
ti porta arricchimento
questo è l'augurio che mando a tutti
quanti scoprire un significa la più
profonda rigenerazione